foreign
let's start this hour off with George in
Charlotte North Carolina hey George how
are you
hey guys good afternoon thank you so
much for taking my call sure man what's
up
so I put myself in the pickle I'm
definitely very embarrassed about it but
um basically had a 2013 Buick Verano
which was driving for work and personal
and it ended up needing a new motor it
was paid off so I traded it in and got
two thousand dollars for it and you know
I wanted to I knew I didn't want to take
out another car loan
um but I ended up going to a Toyota
dealership because we didn't have much
cash to buy something you know from a
friend and so look around the 2016
Toyota Corolla for 15.5 bought the uh
the loan total loan came out to 17. and
so um we got it two days later it
stopped I was at the dealership for
another issue and the check engine light
was on went back to the car uh car
didn't turn on
obviously we were upset I was upset and
scared because of my so many issues in
my previous vehicle
um they were trying to sell us for a car
which was you know kind of overpriced
than what they sell it for online and so
we kind of just left the dealership my
friend told me that I can just cancel
that loan and get a different car and I
foolishly went on the weekend to get a
different car much more expensive uh
2020 Toyota Camry for 26k and now I have
two loans
um and I'm in communication with the
first uh Toyota dealership but they have
no legal obligations to let me out and
uh I'm just trying to see what the best
solution is how old are you
I'm 32.
how do you
where'd you get the idea that your
friend was not a brainless idiot
you don't call your friend and ask about
a fifteen thousand dollar loan your
friend is not a lawyer or a judge is he
an Alabama fan too oh I'm just kidding
that was a dealer dig
oh my gosh George
yeah he uh well he purchased his cards
and uh sells them you know overseas and
so I kind of was you know he said he
does all the time he buys some
dealerships all the time and so
I mean I'm not even putting the blame on
him I made the decision at the end of
the day and you know I'm just trying to
think how can yeah I'm just saying the
process you used to make the bad
decision was a bad process thus it led
to a bad decision like you took advice
from an idiot okay
um
wow
and then you upgraded your mistake
you were like man I made a tough
decision hold my own beer yeah I can I
can do another one man so now you have
40 000 in car debt because your old car
that was two thousand dollars broke
that's the end of the story and what do
you guys make
uh we're about my wife has part-time
she's in school right now and so I think
she's making around 10 and I make forty
eight five
okay so you have to sell both vehicles
sir that's what I want to do and I know
I'm taking a loss and I'm just trying to
figure out what the best way to do it I
went I met with the manager from the
first vehicle 2016 Toyota and you know
just you know kind of let them know hey
you know there was a few issues with
purchasing that vehicle I mean after the
purchase such as like I said check
engine light car doesn't stop I mean I
was at the dealership that didn't start
right in front of the dealership and
then the sales agent
um you know stopped working the other
day after for some reason so I mean I
feel like I have a few
kind of grievances that I can
um bring to the table to try to get out
of this thing and I'm supposed to meet
with the general manager to like maybe
this week what the GM's probably going
to do is offer to fix the car and
they're going to do just enough to get
that light off and say yeah go about
your way right so yeah and then you're
selling it and then you sell the other
one and you get your two thousand dollar
car
yeah so
2020
. Hey listen I wouldn't sell the cars
since since they're both on a loan like
how would I you're gonna take a bath and
you're gonna sell your loan you're gonna
go from forty thousand dollars of debt
to seven thousand dollars of debt yeah
you're gonna have to run down to the
credit union and borrow the difference
and borrow the 2 000 to get your little
beater car to get driving around or
maybe you could put them up on Facebook
Marketplace and sell them for exactly
what you want them you might you might
get out of them for what you owe on them
but I doubt it it sounds like you
specialized in overpaying as well
um
the um
so here's the thing man I'm sorry you've
gone through this
um you have accurately identified the
problem and he's the guy in your mirror
I've done stupid stuff too so I'm not
just picking on you but
um when I do something when I have done
something like this
um
uh
and I have to write a check for my
stupidity I call it stupid tax
and so you're probably whatever you're
upside down on these cars whatever
amount you have to borrow to get rid of
these two cars is the amount of your
stupid tax because you got very
emotional and very frustrated
first at the two thousand dollar car
breaking and then the one you just
bought you were pissed off and scared
and felt inept and whatever else and so
then you go buy a 26 000 car because the
check engine light goes on
um and
you know uh uh you you've got to get rid
of these cars George for several reasons
number one they were done purchases
number two keeping them is even dumber
and number three son every time you pay
this payment you're gonna feel dumb yeah
and George this this really quickly over
a weekend established a pattern where
you get frustrated with something and
you go make a rash Choice and then you
get frustrated with that rash toys and
my guess is we could look at your life
your relationships your work performance
and this is a pattern so here's what I
want you to do I want you to start
catching yourself
when you get frustrated when you get mad
when your heart starts beating you start
clenching your fist your hands start
getting a little bit clammy whatever
happens with you
pause call somebody get a friend that
you say hey when I get out of control I
do stupid stuff like buy two cars in the
same weekend by the way it's a Camry and
a curl like it's not like these are
dream cars you just uh yeah you got
scared man so have a buddy that you call
reach out to and let's pause this
Behavior so we can start catching
ourselves before we do something dumb
again when I did one like this a guy
gave me a scripture and I'll give it to
you
Proverbs says he who is impulsive
exalts folly
and my friend explained to me that the
word Folly is a verb that means a fool
in action
when you are impulsive you are a fool in
action when I am impulsive I am a fool
in action
and that's what got you here my brother
and so you're gonna you're gonna write
some stupid texts I'm sorry you're going
through this and we'll help you any way
we can
this is the Ramsey Show